welcome to this video in a new part of
the series on end game strategy yeah we
look at them position here from the game
banco playing white against bruno farmer
playing black yeah this is the position
after or before move on 25 yeah it's a
simplified position and already an
endgame rather quickly in this game how
to assess the situation yeah it is in a
way simple but also complicated it is
some pretty clear that white is better
here but it's not so clear how much
advantage he actually has yeah why it's
white better get is because of Bishop
against night the bishop here in this
open position is some the better minor
piece it simply is the long-range piece
that can work on both flanks sorry a7 is
not meant to be marked it can work on
both sides of the board combined but the
night has a very limited range also the
bishop is attacking along this diagonal
and can put pressure on f7 which gets
especially interesting in connection
with putting a look on the 7th here is
the second thing that is in whites favor
here his roofs are already positioned on
the open files and are close to entering
on the 7th in this concrete position
white could not do it immediately like
this because of 95 and it all yeah
evaporates to nothing this is also
explaining why its next move he plays
the good move Bishop to be three
voluntary retreat which makes sure that
95 here is not coming with the temple
yeah in this situation on black decided
to play Knight to f6 which does make
some sense the nitrogen retreats from
this in stable unstable g4 square and
comes back to f6 note that a very
important point is that the night does
not have a stable outpost somewhere this
is a huge difference to a position on
whether with a different pawn structure
yeah let's say for argument's sake um
the situation would be would be somewhat
would be somewhat different for example
let's say the pawn would be here you
just to make a point and the night is
here then why it has nothing absolutely
nothing because this night is rock
stable it will just stay there forever
and black has no problems whatsoever i
add king here rook c8 and we start to
maneuver and there's nothing special
going on in this this kind of position
in the game however going going back in
the game however this night after Bishop
b3 Knight f6 we see that this has no
stable outpost that can never be posted
anywhere where it is safely protected
and cannot easily be pushed away you can
say you could put it on c5 true but
before we'll come at some point um yeah
why played kingi to using the king this
does make sense and black now decided to
take off the roofs with rook takes e1
there this looks appealing a bit
accommodating but it is very difficult
to avoid in the long run anyway let's
say black is not doing that is to place
King g7 instead after this what can go
something like this king of three maybe
h5 to limit White's advance on the King
side and then why'd will probably play
rook see one yeah and this intends to
capture on c8 and then play rook c7 and
here black is probably forced now to do
this and now ruki eight leading to the
type of yeah that the position in the
game well let's say this also
interesting trying to play rugby seven
roof d7 by the way is a threat here in a
way because if black can put the rook on
g7 covering the sound rank this has them
yeah it's not like a fortress but it's
it's very difficult to break down so
probably right we'll play rookie 7 and
after Luke d7 we reached the same type
of endgame as in the game it is very
difficult to avoid in the long run so I
understand why black simply am yeah went
for radium here he took only one rook
takes rook e8 yeah just going to this
end game directly yeah White has no
choice here he took it if he tries to
avoid the rook trade this would be
interesting if he would really count to
c7 but black will go here and cover on
the 7th rank and try staying on here
with some chances to to succeed of
course maybe better chances then after
the rook trade so white trade it and
played king of three yeah how is this
end game to be evaluated and get pretty
much the same as the starting position
white is better can you win hmm yeah in
the practical game yeah probably in
analysis maybe not this is one of those
borderline situations where definitely
one side is better but it is not so easy
to give a clear-cut scientific
evaluation it's one of those cases where
you think like okay there should be some
clear assessment like draw win lost
something like that but this is
difficult to do in analysis what i'm
doing here is i'm presenting you how the
game went and i'm showing you some
typical things that could have happened
to show the points of this bishop roses
night type of endgame let's see the next
moves I think are very logical king of
ATM using the king and now like when
night c7 this prevents the King from
coming up to d5 c6 immediately
makes lots of sense age form yeah a
typical space gay now white will need to
push the pawns to gain space and
ultimately fix weaknesses here on the on
the kingside kini seven yeah taking up
this this locating position of the king
it's not so easy now for why to break
through if we see the night it's
covering this the pawn is covering c5
and so on so black has some sort of
defensive set up why this gaining space
and form age six note that um here moves
like f5 yeah would be a huge mistake
right we'll we'll go up and we'll come
ultimately to g8 to attack those pawns
on light squares yeah that's a big
commitment stay a black black plate not
f5 but h6 this is better just staying in
a way right now went Bishop c4 that's a
very typical not to move that is so it's
not necessarily the best one like g4 was
also okay but it's a very typical thing
to put the bishop exactly here where it
exerts this influence on both diagonals
and it limits blacks bishop black
special exhibition next night the night
is somewhat dominated now like a six
beef of those squares are all controlled
by the night note that also why does of
course enjoying a space advantage this
space advantage is very very useful and
can be the decisive factor in lots of
arising positions also in positions
where the bishop is trading itself
against the night sometimes you can
transpose into winning king and phone
and game because of your huge space
advantage and then zoosk want positions
that you that you might get ya black now
played King to f6 is just waiting
basically
g-form King e7 it's not he didn't have
any big big alternative to waiting if
you move the night white will enter here
and you can basically just shuffle with
the king yeah white now played King to
e5 yeah this is a a good move that sort
of forces the situation if you want what
is black doing now he cannot shuttle
anymore with his King obviously if you
go here white will enter so the King
cannot really move in this position what
is what what can like do here yeah he
only has two real choices um because
well pawn moves out of the question
besides f6 switches which is the game
continuation but let's say b5 yeah
justice just to look at it this kind of
move is not good simply because it puts
this pawn on them on a square where is
attacked him like here and the bishop is
always attacking this now and note that
this is an additional problem you have
weakened squares so this putting
something on light squares where it is
about to be fixed possibly um it's not a
good idea the same time we move like a
five is not a good idea as b6 is an
additional weakness and easier yeah you
can attack this much easier then the
pawn on a seven for example oh this is
not helping black so we mostly have to
look at two moves f6 check which he
played in the game or 98 this is also an
interesting interesting trial let's have
a look at this 98 yeah how does white
continue from here I think I'm awaiting
move like Bishop b3 this make sense you
can try to try to play that yeah but
it's not immediately rewarded like an
even I cannot go back I'm sorry i cannot
go to the seven because of Bishop b5 but
96 is a is a possible defense where you
cannot advance here this is also a
reason for
d3 move we you'd sort of remove the
bishop from the influence of the night
coming to d6 so Bishop d3 96 this is the
idea of the 98 movie are switching the
defensive position of the night 26 red
is a little bit more active yeah how do
we continue from here g5 very typical
gaining more space and fixing horns on
light squares black am Pro take and now
an interesting moment right now as this
typical choice to take with this or take
with the airport what is better yeah I
think white should take with the f porn
actually this has an a.1 specific reason
I'm then it does not matter and what
pawn stands on g5 for the simple
function of fixing the f porn this is
not really measuring the question is is
it more valuable to have the H bonus
backup or the F porn and in the end game
very often thinks them a little bit
different than in the middle game where
you almost all of the time prefer to
have a central pawn in the end game the
outside points h pawn a pawn can be a
very valuable especially if you fight
against the night those are notoriously
difficult to fight for nights because
nights are such a short range pieces
very often here in this type of firm
position you can imagine maybe at some
point white can enter one of six and
let's say sacrifices on g6 when you get
two pawns yeah two to run and in this
case the two outside pawns the h point
especially is much more variable than
having the f porn because the h pawn is
much harder to stop for the night this
is one reason why i think this captures
better it's very often a good idea to
capture outside I mean away from the
center to get outside passes in the long
run yeah black mostly we'll just just
wait IAM and this is not totally
conclusive analysis I just
to show some typical ideas what white
needs to do here he needs to gain space
as much space as possible yeah this is
not force I'm just showing some sub
typical musiah wide will advance and it
will get to something like that and here
it is some quite clear that black is is
suffering a lot because he can hardly
move young it's very difficult to to do
something here you're basically yeah
forced to him to shuffle but how is
white actually winning let's look at
some some typical maneuvers white can
try to Toulouse Tempe and so on to
ultimately force the black king back
yeah something like this can be can be
reached now the night cannot move as a
six Hanks so the King has to move and
then we ultimately enter kini 8 in
something something like that but how do
we win how do we win yeah it's not so
easy in fact there is a there is a
winning idea and the idea is to change
the pawn structure with the idea to play
a for this is some the decisive maneuver
in this position where at the end the
bishop would come here to simultaneously
attack a 6 + f7 it wasn't possible for
the bishop before when there was still
an a and B porn on the board it wasn't
possible for for the white Bishop to
attack both and now he will win one of
the pawns note that for example if we
look at this here white will win but
maybe to f8 but it is not not a
difference here yeah um it's probably
here in this case when there would be an
f porn it's just just to win as well but
with the H porn it is it is just simpler
simpler to do because the night cannot
really fight this at all yeah also note
that there is always some there are
always ideas of domination yeah like
Bishop before most like that
yeah so this is ultimately getting to
results one type of position where you
use your long-range piece to to to lose
and gain 10 beam and yeah at the end
attack the weaknesses that the knighting
king cannot defend just a typical
development in this kind of endgame it's
not a forced analysis i just want to
show typical idea so i'm going back to
the to the start of it King e5 yeah
black decided to play f6 I think this is
actually the better defense yeah then
better defense than 98 f 6 yeah white
went back so kini 5 has provoked this um
this pawn move black now went King to f8
yeah here there is again a case where
something else could be tried for
example 98 again this regrouping now
that f6 has been played yeah how does
some white continue from here yeah
Kingda 597 King c6 this is very logical
and looks at first it looks like this is
like an easy win but it's not that easy
black can play for counter play with f5
you have the ideas that white takes we
only the sudden get the H poorness black
not very advisable so g5 of course is
better black takes this is this is
absolutely necessary to get some sort of
counter play if you play this and you
cannot even go to h5 then why it wins
very simply actually because this is a
total domination of the of the of the
night and the King cannot really move as
Bishop f7 comes and here white we'll
just yeah push on the queenside and then
end them was decisive effect it's a
pretty pretty simple win so black has to
take it and again it's this capture here
it is for concrete reasons if you take
like this
like will immediately get the pawn even
this is not not totally clear five black
saves himself but it's just much better
to take with the f porn not for some
strategic reason but for some concrete
reason as mentioned it gives him a
passer but the past point is very nicely
controlled by a long-range piece yeah
now for example 98 King be seven losses
apiece due to 96 so we voluntarily
retreat 96 and a four and now we see
this typical dilemma the bishop again is
dominating the night you cannot push the
f porn as g6 faults you cannot really
have a can move king e6 but what is it
doing for you wyd in the meantime we'll
we'll push pawns gain space and
ultimately enter to win they upon yeah
this is this is quite the same why does
gaining this space yeah the corn is very
dangerous and white has won the pawn at
the end so this is a very typical
scenario the space advantage and the
better the long wage minor piece wins at
the end I think this this 98 defends is
not not very promising I think what you
play it actually king of aid is is quite
okay right now play it the move h5 an
interesting decision but I think a good
decision it is a bit counterintuitive it
to us maybe to put something on light
squares as you sort of always things you
shouldn't put them on the color complex
of your bishop but it's still the right
decision and the decision is is right
because it forces the Jeep on to move
and this means that you have a an idea
how to enter with your king it just
paves the way for the king this move and
this is more important the move like g5
which fixes the weakness on g6 has 11
problem if we look at something like
this you see that it's very difficult
now to make any headway black might even
go night is 6
to put pressure on on those two and if
we trade him or something like this it
gets to the point where you simply
cannot win anymore because of reduced
material this is some not possible h5 is
just better white and white played this
I think exactly right so h5 yeah and now
I think exactly here like a black place
them may be the decisive mistake it's
not so not so easy to say well let's say
I know that what he played is losing but
i'm not sure if the other move would
would have saved him he applied g5 now
and this is when we look at the game
pretty clearly losing um not not a good
defense taking on h5 was much tougher we
can look at this I'm not totally sure at
wide wins um in them in the book that I
that I have this famous book by Michael
cheryshev ski about end game strategy um
they say that or cheryshev ski says that
white should win here as well which I'm
not totally convinced off really yeah if
white white recaptures of course and now
in the book they just say and wide will
enter with King f5 and so on the problem
is that this is not happening there is
98 and white is not entering with King
f5 because of 96 so um the whole idea is
nice but it's not so yeah so so easily
realized and white is nevertheless
clearly better the question is only at
least for me if it is a clear-cut win on
oh it's not not that too that easy what
is best here yeah I think I move like
Bishop e2 is quite good covering this
and preparing king d 5 yeah we also i
mean kingdom on kingda 5 wasn't doing
much okay and
he could have played kingdom five let's
start with that I need to show you my
rationale behind Bishop b2 we can also
start with this King King d5 and try to
try to enter immediately 97 Bishop e2
ke7 King c6 this kind of thing is is
very good for white like us getting this
pawn but why does getting this on a 7
yeah why it's the lesser chances here
with the with the the pawn here that
look that will emerge on the queenside
but if it's a win it's not that clear if
you start with Bishop b2 here start with
Bishop b2 um it's not so well sorry not
him start here there should be two um it
is some it is much more interesting the
reason is now if black plays Knight g7
you have this additional news you're not
going king be five you're limiting the
night along those diagonals and after
for example King is seven there is not
really another move King d5 again we
have a domination situation of the night
f5 for example this should be one back
King f6 yeah you cannot go here because
kingly five were directly win this pawn
king f6 and only now do we enter 96 king
be seven cakes and this is a much more
favorable version of the end game that
we had seen before now the king is on f6
and we will get the porn on a seven if
we look at this
we see that why does reroute his King
towards here and then he will push the
pawn in the other situation we had the
King on a 7 which couldn't really escape
so this is like a much better version of
that um this whole analysis here is not
totally conclusive and due to too
limited time it's not so easy to work it
out totally the thing is that white will
always be better because he will get the
a pawn for the 8th porn and then in this
kind of race you have the outside passer
which is more valuable this version here
with Bishop b2 if we go back to the
initial position here this version with
Bishop e2 Bishop g4 is just a little bit
done better in comparison by the way
after Bishop e2 instead of night g7
black can also try King e7 of course
after which we now have the chance to
enter yeah going all the way to do six
black cannot really prevent a tanking of
seven we get this check so it is some it
is also very much favorable for white
but I'm not so it is not as easy as
after g5 after g5 in the game white of
course captured and went king air five
yeah invasion king g7 the only move King
e5 and we combine this at this this is
also great square leg covers that and we
enter with the bishop okay now we're in
a position where we are really
dominating proceedings this Bishop is
covering g4 nicely nothing happening
there and blankets totally passed if you
cannot really move anything anything
great so what is why doing we are
gaining maximum space before 98 and now
note that white is playing this very
strong fashion b5 yeah Knight f6 a form
putting everything on
squares yeah counterintuitive but this
is ultimately very strong what white is
doing is it's basically claiming okay at
the end I will win this pawn not much
that you can do about it and I rather
have my pawns advanced beforehand before
i take the pawn because at the end i
need to to promote them so I advance
them first and only then do I start this
march to win the a6 a7 pawn this is
happening now why does improving his
pieces to the utmost yeah and now we are
heading to a seven yup he has made the
best possible progress with the spawns
before he took the pawn king at 69 f6
Bishop c6 this has a direct technical
idea it's giving up the ponyo but now
that comes a five and this is a already
forced porn promotion and all possible
because we had used our our time wisely
by pushing the pawns yeah and after this
move black resigned the point is just
that's just promoting note that really
putting the pawns on light squares was
the totally right decision here because
we are already dominating we are not in
a situation where this is a bad bishop
yeah it controls like the whole board so
on this was the right term the right way
to play ultimately as mentioned you get
the pawn on a seven and you want those
as far advanced as possible yeah this is
a nice and very let's say a pure example
of the bishop being the more promising
minor piece in an open position where
there is play on both flanks it is some
clear then why it is better as mentioned
quite often but it's not so clear if you
can can really win what you can do
however is you can make those little
improving maneuvers and moves that
increase the pressure
on your opponent and with good
maneuvering you very often will be able
to win the game it is not totally clear
to me if this is some a win in some
lines would be an interesting project if
you have hours and hours to really
determine the win or find out if there
is a win but it's quite clear that you
should always try to use your advantage
share of the the better minor piece this
was meant to give you some ideas and
typical maneuvers um at hand so if you
get to this situation get to make the
best out of it and put pressure on the
opponent as much as possible yeah I hope
you enjoyed this example of endgame
strategy Bishop against night thanks for
watching